you also are questionable I kind of want
to vote you because like that's easy but
then I'm kind of like but are you
throwing this out to throw us off of you
[Music]
[Applause]
we brought together seven Beyonce fans
I'm a Beyonce thing I am a Beyonce fan I
am a Beyonce fan I am would be on
station I am in Beyonce I am a Beyonce
I'm a Beyonce fed one is a liar if the
group discovers who the liar is they'll
split a cash prize if the liar survives
he or she wins the entire prize
ah who hates Beyonce who thought a
Beyonce Netflix special I think the
whole world say I'm gonna be honest I
didn't see it
what is Beyonce homecoming about I don't
I didn't see it it just went so fast
everyone was talking over each other and
I knew the decision that came out of
that would not have been good mind you
this is what my spot if I was on when I
came here oh we don't know that in the
beginning round I thought for sure that
it was Kody I've got artists of the same
genre but you don't know I'm getting
Lauren here and Erica by doodly so that
not Beyonce what Austin Powers movie did
Beyonce play look I'm just gonna be real
I think we shall I could be making it
about like Beyonce herself not like
where she's in or what she's doing and
so like the music itself
music the whole basis of the game was
love and hate so I knew people that were
spitting the facts
that's where hate becomes you have to be
knowledgeable on what you hate you're a
liar Oh was just like yep I'm here I
thought he didn't know anything
I knew is between me and Cody 100 almost
hundred percent knew Cody wasn't the
mole but I still voted for him to saying
I thought that I could sway people later
on I saw him and I saw him I counted the
letter who do we know for sure I think I
think you're a Beyonce fan for sure
y'all who are questionable let's go
around at least really quickly and say
when did we fall in love with Beyonce
whoa I found love with Destiny's Child
with the song Dangerously in Love okay
and I was like deeply obsessed with this
guy named Runa he had like brown eyes
and they also had a song brown eyes
maybe say my name I was like the first
one I saw singing and dancing and like
moving and stuff like I have a question
who wasn't the original Destiny's Child
like all of them Beyonce mm-hmm Kelly
Rowland huh then Bri I think that's all
I know then I wouldn't know when I just
saw the Netflix special I just saw like
her work ethic I saw like how she put
that whole thing together but whatever
[Music]
everybody's already like Beyonce you
know already like all her song can you
understand why someone wouldn't like
Beyonce that's for like a Beyonce stand
right and as a fan I'm just crazy in
love you can't understand if somebody
said oh I don't like Beyonce you'll be
like what why are we just why are we
just writing you guys off is all y'all
just jumped on somebody and so I was
trying to bring reason to it a little
bit and figure out like why are we
jumping on this person you have more
like a stronger argument than hi I
believe him I think we should be talking
about everyone's arguments as well you
say everybody because he want to keep
the focus off himself by trying to turn
it around in a very non discreet way I
just became the focal point for more
attacks this is how we go put it to rest
right
do a part of the single ladies dance
Beyonce I'm alright what do you do it -
okay back-to-back do it turn his back
okay see me do it so Casey and you yeah
it seemed if you don't know that I can
do like the main move I don't know
anything like else he don't know this yo
but I also kind of believe that more and
this is like the most known move at
least Raul he like tried to do something
it didn't look good but he tried he was
trying to do more like this in the box
where she put his stuff what direction
did she put it what direction was it to
the left once that four of them were
united I knew it was like kind of game
over there do we know her birthday oh I
do you guys know her birthday I do it
didn't feel like they weren't fans I
didn't get the vibe that they were like
crazy about Beyonce but I also didn't
get the vibe but they hate it Beyonce I
don't I don't know I was gonna say like
facts I don't think that's not being a
fans about
the reason I voted for image is that
dancing I'm not trying to be shady but
like nothing personal honey no I don't
think that was the right decision should
we talk about one song that hits home
I love halo I can see your halo that's a
great song beautiful song oh do you know
any more other than the course
everywhere as soon as the four of them
banded together I knew I was next
so I was I was trying to fight I would
say love drought no random person is
love drought
I do love six-inch heels yeah like I
feel like a baddie when I listen to it
fancy bye bye Destiny's Child like I
think it was from fulfilled my gut told
me Brandon after that I was like wait
wait wait something's off here
someone can know like a bunch of stuff
about Beyonce but still hate on her but
are you throwing this out to throw us
off of you know I feel like Kody was the
mole Rahul
he got very sort of like aggressive ish
you shouldn't know the dance you
shouldn't know the songs you should have
no facts I'm like what what do you what
do you know about Beyonce I kind of want
to vote you because like that's easy
yeah but then I'm kind of like huh you
know how the Beehive works the haters
are part of the group that's what I
think we're good I don't yeah but I
think we should just vote you out for
security and then because you could feel
like the energy in this damn square
luminar owners on a pyramid I think
she's the boss a hater
let Lord Jesus write me now I just
without I'm a vote for you sure you are
but that one person imma be hot if
somebody but you don't go out 1% for him
I don't know I think it's fair that
y'all go ahead to go ahead ahead I do
believe that we already got them all and
I do believe he knows more about Beyonce
than I do just want to clarify that
before we even started to we'll see and
I listen to like the music but I was
also big on Beyonce's like movie career
how come on as long as you name was
Destiny's Child and not just Beyonce
because that's when my love for Beyonce
started
that's true everyone has a no I think
you're safe I think you're saying so you
have one person about me I got like 10%
about you
I do think man I don't think you talked
about your movie career like she did a
movie on MTV I feel like that's the
stuff that haters know actually her
movie career OC I loved it's like you
see her and obsessed when she's like you
think I'm crazy I show Ukraine try me
[ __ ] so I think it's safe to say we're
all Beyonce fans is it too late to
change our minds or do we really gotta
go somebody else ha ha
can't we delivery in the corner why
can't it was the most about Beyonce I
was absolutely terrified that I was
gonna get voted out I don't know her
middle name like I barely know my middle
name on a given day cuz that doesn't
automatically make a fan true you could
have studied I don't study but I know my
queen I don't know you outside of the
square okay thank I thought like we had
already gotten the mole out I feel bad
I'm starin I feel like I'm about to get
Bow Wow no sweating my contour off it
was you its appalled
it's Yin sir it's him it's you Destiny's
Child my this you I think it's Ben no I
think it's you it's you it's Britney
[ __ ] I knew it was you [ __ ] it's all
about Britney you cannot trust anyone
it's I am my mind is blown I'm [ __ ]
pissed like I'm really [ __ ] pissed
right now I didn't know I had that in me
girl
like I knew I was shady but I didn't
know I was a liar do something
I lied real quick that's crazy bro it
fell you see if you're a Britney fan
this is what you get the reason I'm a
Beyonce hater is her fans are so
aggressive and rude I mentioned that
Beyonce wasn't my favorite person first
thing that I start getting is you're fat
you're ugly the F word you should go
kill yourself and I didn't say anything
negative about her character or anything
I just said
I enjoy Britney Spears more Beyonce
knows that beehive is so aggressive she
should come out and say look we already
live in such a terrible world let's just
be nice with each other and if someone
doesn't like me who cares groupthink
happened that's what caused the mole to
win that's what this whole thing is
about who we think people are based on
their looks and I also realize that you
don't have to be aggressive and maybe
that sometimes I should tone it down
when someone doesn't like someone I like
I'm more mad that I didn't see it coming
but I guess I kind of did but I didn't
want to think that he would betray me
like that which is dumb because we only
have like a 30-minute conversation like
what the hell does he owe me I did feel
bad with Tamera and Spencer because we
did form like a little cute relationship
but you know $600 will help me feel
better
Oh five hundred hey guys I hope you
enjoyed the episode by the way this is
Erin if you haven't met her yet she's
one of our fantastic directors so if
you've ever played mafia or werewolf
we'd basically decided let's take that
party game and throw it into a series
but make it about judgment and bias
because I'm honestly fascinated by like
mob mentality and groupthink and how
that can blind us how judgements form
what were your judgments watching who
did you resonate with what judgments
were thrown out the window when you
found who did you think the mole was
what did you think that ball was stick
around for the other episodes they're
coming soon follow us on Instagram we
have a lot of exclusive content there we
hope to see you guys again soon alright
peace out guys